[Applause]
okay thank you thank you i haven't been
on the show yet so i have to figure out
where i am
i need it's crazy backstage there's a
lot of ghosts
[Laughter]
getting in street clothes i saw a lot of
ghosts saying hey that was a good job to
each other all right all right
so uh yeah this is my friend said to me
he said i think the weather's trippy i
said no man it's not the weather that's
trippy perhaps it's the way that we
perceive it that is indeed trippy
and i thought man i should just say yeah
all right i want to hang a map of the
world in my house
and then when i put pins into all the
locations that i travel to but first i
have to travel to the top two corners of
the map
so it won't fall down
[Applause]
i got it i get a cold sore you know i
hate it i put i put carmex on it karmix
is supposed to heal cold sores i don't
know if it does
but it will make them shiny and more
noticeable
it's like cold sore a high lighter maybe
they could come up with an arrow
that heals cold sores
i hate arrows man don't you
imagine imagine being killed by a bow
and arrow that would suck an arrow
killed you
they would never solve the crime look at
that dead guy
let's go that way
i like waffles waffles are like pancakes
with syrup traps
a waffle says this syrup hold on now you
ain't going anywhere
don't even be trying to creep down the
side
just rest in these squares if one square
is full move on to the next one
when you hit the butter split out
i'm sick of soup of the day man it's
time we make a decision
i need to know what soup from now on is
hey
when gator when gatorade has a
commercial they always have like a guy
playing sports
i don't think you have to like be
playing sports and sweating to enjoy a
gatorade
i just think you can be a thirsty dude
gatorade forgets about this demographic
i'm thirsty for absolutely no reason
other than the fact that liquid has not
touched my lips for some time
can i have a gatorade too or does that
lightning bolt mean no
i do play golf though i suck at golf i
never got a hole in one but i did
hit a guy and that's way more satisfying
[Music]
why why why'd they do that shot you see
that
they showed my shoes for a second
put it back
all right forget the rest of that joke i
had a lot more on the golf
without i'll save it for maybe they'll
bring me back
i'd like to go fishing and catch a fish
stick that would be convenient
i would only have to reheat it you know
this fishing show on tv
they catch a fish but then they let it
go they don't want to eat the fish but
they do want to make it late for
something
where were you i got caught
no you didn't let me see the inside of
your lip
you know what a company wants to use
letters in their phone number to be
catchy but often times you use too many
letters like give us a call down here at
1-800 i really enjoy
carpeting it's too many letters man do i
have to dial them all hello hold on i'm
only on enjoy
how did you know i was calling you're
good i can see why i hired you
i like the hotels that have the rotating
restaurants you know i've never been in
a rotating restaurant but one time i
took my girlfriend to a merry-go-round i
put her on it and i gave her a burrito
all right it's my last joke right here i
got an oscillating fan at my house you
know the fan goes back
and forth it oscillates looks like the
fan is saying no
so i like to ask you questions that a
fan would say no to
say do you keep your my hair in place
no you don't do you keep my papers in
order
that's another right answer do you have
three settings
liar thank you all right thank you
you